This research considered various
configurations of the beds in a surgical
suite and their impact on
the overall efficiency of the suite.
Traditionally, there
are three types of beds,
the pre operative holding area, where
patients are held before the surgery.
The post anesthesia care unit where
patients go immediately after surgery,
and the level 2 area, where they
recover further from the surgery.
Georgia Tech researchers developed
a model using a tool called MED-BPM,
a healthcare specific modeling tool,
and showed that an alternative approach
using universal beds that could be
reconfigured for all three purposes
could serve the same number of cases,
but with substantially fewer beds.